in terms of the actual mechanism of how
AI might kill all humans
so something you've been outspoken about
you've talked about a lot is it
autonomous weapon systems
so the use of AI in war is that one of
the things that still you carry concern
for as these systems become more and
more powerful and carry a concern for it
not that all humans are going to get
killed by slaughterbots but rather just
as uh the express route into orwellian
dystopia where it becomes much easier
for very few to kill very many and
therefore it becomes very easy for very
few to dominate very many right
um
yeah if you want to know how I could
kill all people just ask yourself how we
humans have driven a lot of species
extinct how do we do it
you know we were smarter than them
usually we didn't do it even
systematically by going around
one-on-one one after the other and
stepping on them or shooting them or
anything like that we just like chop
down their habitat because we needed it
for something else
in some cases we did it by putting more
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere because
of some reason that those animals didn't
even understand and now they're gone
right uh so if
um if you're in Ai and you just wanna
figure something out then you decide you
know we just really need um the space
here to build more compute facilities
you know
if that's the only goal it has you know
we are just the sort of accidental
roadkill along the way and you could
totally imagine yeah maybe this oxygen
is kind of annoying because it caused
more corrosion so let's get rid of the
oxygen
and good luck surviving after that you
know I I'm not particularly concerned
that they would want to kill us just
because
that would be like
a goal in itself you know when we
've driven the number we've driven a
number of elephant species extinct right
it wasn't because we didn't like
elephants
what the basic problem is you just don't
want to give you don't want to seed
control over your planet to some other
more intelligent entity that doesn't
share your goals it's that simple so
which brings us to another key challenge
which AI safety researchers have been
grappling with for a long time like how
do you make AI
first of all understand our goals and
then adopt our goals and then retain
them as they get smarter right and um
all three of those are really hard right
like
a human child first they're just not
smart enough to understand our goals
we can't even talk
and then eventually they're teenagers
and understand our goals just they don't
share yeah
but there is unfortunately a magic space
in the Middle where they're smart enough
to understand our goals and malleable
enough that we can hopefully with good
parenting and teach them right from
wrong and instead good goal there's
still good goals in them right and
so those are all tough challenges with
computers and then you know even if you
teach your kids good goals when they're
little they might outgrow them to and
that's a challenge for machines to keep
improving so these are a lot of hard
hard challenges we're up for but I don't
think any of them are insurmountable
the fundamental reason why
Eliezer looked so depressed when I last
saw him was because he felt it just
wasn't enough time oh not that it was
unsolvable because there's just not
enough time he was hoping that Humanity
was going to take this threat more
seriously so we would have more time
yeah and now we don't have more time
that's why the open letter is calling
for more time
but even with time the AI alignment
problem
seems to be really difficult oh yeah
but it's also the most worthy problem
the most important problem for Humanity
to ever solve because if we solve that
one Lex
that aligned AI can help us solve all
the other problems
because it seems like it has to have
constant humility
about his goal constantly question the
goal
because as you optimize towards a
particular goal and you start to achieve
it that's when you have the unintended
consequences all the things you
mentioned about so how do you enforce
and code a constant humility as your
ability become better and better and
better and better Stuart Professor
Stuart Russell Berkeley who's also one
of the
foreign
driving forces behind this letter he uh
has a whole research program about this
I think of it as yeah humility exactly
although he calls it inverse
reinforcement learning and other nerdy
terms but it's about exactly that
instead of telling the AI here's his
goal go optimize the bejesus out of it
you tell it okay
do what I want you to do but I'm not
going to tell you right now what it is I
want you to do you need to figure it out
so then you give the incentive to be
very humble and keep asking you
questions along the way is this what you
really meant is this what you wanted and
oh this the other thing I tried didn't
work seemed like it didn't work out
right should I try it differently
what's nice about this is it's not just
philosophical mumbo jumbo it's theorems
and Technical work that with more time I
think it can make a lot of progress and
there are a lot of brilliant people now
working on AI safety and we're just not
we just need to give them a bit more
time but also not that many relative to
the skill of the problem no way exactly
there should be
at least this just like every University
worth its name has some cancer research
going on in its biology Department right
every University that's computer that
does computer science should have a real
effort in this area and it's nowhere
near that this is something I hope is
changing now thanks to the gpt4 right so
I I think
if there's a silver lining to um what's
happening here even though I think many
people would wish it would have been
rolled out more carefully is that this
might be the wake-up call
that Humanity needed
to really
stop the stop fantasizing about this
being a hundred years off and stop
fantasizing about this being completely
controllable and predictable because
it's so obvious it's it's not
predictable you know why is it that open
that that
I think it was GP chat GPT tried to
persuade um
a journalist or was it before to divorce
his wife you know it was not because the
the engineers who built it was like
let's put this in here and and screw a
little bit with people
they haven't predicted at all they built
a giant black box and
trained to predict the next word and got
all these emergent properties and oops
it did this you know
um
I I think this is a very powerful
wake-up call and now anyone watching
this is not scared I would encourage
them to just play a bit more with these
these tools they're out there now like
gpd4
and um
so wake-up call is First Step once
you've broken up uh then gotta slow down
a little bit the risky stuff
to give a chance to oh everyone's woken
up to to catch up with us on the safety
front